- I have this drone
pretty much entirely done.
And I've even managed to
bind it to this controller.
There is some sort of connection.
But I can't control the motors.
(upbeat pop music)
- It's awesome.
- [Man] Are they gonna
find some for the rain?
- It's fine but not for shoes.
- Today has been a disaster.
Because it is pouring rain.
What I did today was ring a
bunch of racing drone parts
for this tiny micro drone that I have.
And I'm going to try to build it
But we'll see if that actually works.
It's about this big.
It's super tiny.
But the problem is, I've
never actually built a
racing drone before.
But I bought the parts.
So hopefully, I can actually
assemble this into something
that I can race next doorr and
mess with all those people.
It's a tiny little motor.
Now we have our control board here.
And this is actually the brains
of the entire drone itself.
It looks like just any
normal computer chip.
Except this has its telemetry stuff on it.
You got a tiny little radio here.
And it will actually power
the motors and the camera.
Look at the size of this thing.
Here is a nickel right next
to the little FPV camera.
This is meant to take a real
live video signal from this
tiny little camera
directly to my eyeballs.
Woah, Look at all that stuff.
(machine whirring)
- Okay, I've never owned an RC boat.
I've always been jealous.
As a child, I go to friends'
houses and some people would
have a swimming people.
And, oh, I wish I had a pool.
And they had an RC Boat.
They drive it around in their pool.
And I was like, "Uhh!"
The street is completely flooded today.
And we have these mini
drones leftover from a shoot
and they have these hydro foils
that should ride on water.
Do you think it's gonna be deep enough?
- I don't know.
My feet are wet.
- I know, this is terrible.
Look, look at.
- It's so deep!
- Look at how much water there is.
(drone whirring)
- It's stuck, it's only sitting.
- Push it out a bit.
Okay.
- Yeah, Yeah, Yeah.
(shouting)
It's going, it's going!
- We gotta, we gotta deepen this thing.
- Oh my, god.
Oh, no, it's gonna get run over!
I've started putting this drone together.
I managed to get the motors
installed in the right spots.
And I've got the control board
pressed on but I haven't got
the screws in yet because I
gotta install the camera first.
But my main issue is,
although I know how to solder,
I'm not particularly good.
Maybe Spencer can solder this on.
'Cause what we have to do is
cut the cable for this and
solder it directly to these
tiny little nodes here.
And I don't quite trust
my own skills soldering.
Soldering skill?
That's the one.
Should I be bold and just solder it myself
or should I get Spencer's help?
My Grandfather's always told me...  Do it!
- I like your grandfather.
I'm gonna do it.
(finger taps the table)
I don't need Spencer's help.
Little nervous.
First thing's first attaching
this little FPV camera to the drone.
Moment of truth, man.
(Hiphop music)
According to that image right there,
red on bottom, black on top.
The red is the power,
the black is the ground.
- Don't mess up.
- I will do my best, Nick.
Please work.
Aha, I got one on there.
Now to do the other.
Did I state that I'm
not very good at this?
(crying)
Okay, I think I got it.
I think I got it.
Just gonna put the liquid tape.
Just a little dab on it.
You know what electrical tape is?
This is essentially
that but in liquid form.
You know what?
That's good enough.
Screw it.
I need a napkin.
(cars passing by)
- Woah, Woah, Woah!
- Oh my, god, Fuck you!
- Did it die?
It says it's not connected.
- I don't think they're waterproof.
- The drone is now probably dead.
- Did you fulfill your childhood fantasy?
- Yeah, it was a brief
10 seconds of just glory.
I was on that little boat sailing.
5.8 knots.
- Was it worth it?
- Yes.
(laughing)
- Play out here, you're
gonna get splashed.
- Why is this so difficult?
Everything should work.
Okay, moment of truth.
(drone beeps)
(heavy drum music)
Why won't it just work?
Come on!
This is so aggravating.
I have this drone pretty
much entirely done.
And I've even managed to
bind it to this controller.
So there is some sort of connection.
But I can't control the motors.
I just wanna go bug the people next door.
- In.
Out.
- Light is blinking.
(drone beeps)
Turn it on.
Light's on.
That means it should be connected now.
The problem I ran into is
that even though I was able
to bind this to my controller,
I wasn't able to get the
motors up and running because
there's a setting that
I didn't actually activate.
It seems obvious in hindsight
but I didn't have a switch
set to arm the motors.
I've now set that switch.
So now, the thing works.
It's weird to, like,
walk around like this.
See, okay.
Here I can walk around just fine.
(Wren grunts)
(Nick laughs)
- Let's see a third
person video game to you.
(electro music)
This is so weird.
(Wren laughs)
(sneezes)
Okay.
All right.
Maiden flight here in the studio.
(drone buzzing)
Woah.
This is not easy to fly, by the way.
Oh, hey, I'm coming up to say hi.
(drone buzzes)
Hey, Jake!
- Hey, guys.
Hi.
- Woah, so fast.
(Wren shouts)
I just crashed upstairs.
I don't know if my skill
level's up to flying next door
but I'm gonna try it.
And like you're grandfather says,
- I haven't told any of
them that I'm gonna do this.
So, let's go do some recon.
- Hey, Wren.
- You show up unannounced and
you're not even gonna tell
me what you're up to?
(heavy drum music)
(claps)
- Hey, here goes nothing.
(drone buzzes)
(heavy drum music)
- It's a great start.
- I'm next door.
I'm next door.
Hey, everyone.
- Are they totally freaking out right now?
(mumbles)
(heavy drum music)
(classic music)
- Hey, I'm trapped!
They put me in prison.
- You know the real test is if
you can go say hi to Brandon.
(suspenseful music)
- All right, I'm in sixth.
No, he's trying to shoot me.
Oh, dang it!
No!
I'm upside down.
Please return me to my glory.
No, it's Kevin.
It's Kevin.
No!
God, I'm trapped in a prison.
This is probably Kevin's doing.
There you are!
(suspenseful music)
Why you do this?
And that my friend is how
you mess with other studios.
- Dude, you got them good.
- Yeah, I did until they
trapped me in a hat prison.
I didn't expect that.
I should have in hindsight.
- Now, if they put a stink
bomb on and you're gonna
drop it on them.
- Dude, stink bomb status?
- Middle school status?
(Wren laughs)
- I call that a success, Nick!
It took us more than a day.
But we got to it in the end.
- Thanks, grandpa.
- Yeah, thanks, grandpa.
(high fives)
Hereditary high five.
(drone buzzes)
(electro music)
He's driving down the thing right now.
- Where?
Where is he?
- Holy (beep).
- Oh, there he is.